each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
I'm going to start um I'm AJ brush and
I'm co-hosting this talk with Rob Reider
who's right there and wave to all of you
um and we are delighted to welcome
Heather Richter lipford who I met when
she was Heather Richter when we were
both actually in a doctor luck what is
that called fact open source contortion
when we were students back in the day
she's now a professor at the University
of North Carolina at Charlotte where she
co-directs the HCI lab and does research
on usable security and privacy and today
she's going to talk about privacy on
social networks Thanks thank you very
much for coming and we're coming to talk
today so start off with a couple of
interesting quotes here a few months ago
the founder of Facebook gave an
interesting statement defending their
recent moves to make more information
public on Facebook by saying that well
the social norms have changed people are
now much more comfortable sharing a lot
more information with more people so
those changes are really just about
reflecting the current social norms and
you've probably all heard various quotes
in the media on things like well you
know privacy is dead get over it you
know if you really don't want something
to be no and you know perhaps you
shouldn't be doing it or you shouldn't
be putting it online in the first place
and a lot of these attitudes seem to be
reflected in the behavior of users on
social network sites so sure you're all
well aware a number of studies
documenting it's just a huge amount of
personal information online in different
sites facebook myspace linkedin and many
others on facebook alone there's three
billion photos a month and 60 million
status updates daily and despite all of
this personal information there's very
little use of privacy controls even when
there are extensive privacy controls and
this isn't just an issue of sharing
information with other people but now a
lot of this personal information is
escaping the social network site itself
and spreading beyond to third-party
developers and
to other sites through Facebook's
application platform and many other
sites have implemented Google's open
social platform as well and so all of
this sharing is despite a lot of media
attention over some of the problems and
was sharing in some very public negative
consequences like the the mi6 Chiefs
photos of his holiday and his you know
swimming shorts and a lot of other media
attention around some of the dangers of
social networking like you know identity
theft um you know stalking spearfishing
for example and still there still seems
to be a lot of sharing going on a lot of
users who don't seem to be all that
concerned about their privacy so I began
my work really interested in what is
that the case did users really just not
care um why are they sharing so much
information on these sites um what do
they think about their privacy and do
they how do they manage it how do they
cope with their privacy online and if
there are issues if there are needs that
we can address how can we make that
management um better so my methodology
through my work usually have started
with a qualitative formative study of a
particular aspect of a social network
site to understand the needs and
behaviors of people and then prototypes
and evaluated new privacy mechanisms and
interfaces for to help address some of
those needs so you'll see that repeated
throughout my talk that methodology so
before I go on in the specifics of what
I've done useful to at least address
well what is privacy and one of the
challenges there is there's a lot of
definitions whether you're looking at it
from a law perspective a philosophical
perspective a social psychology
perspective well these are social
network sites so a lot of users concerns
are more of the the social in nature so
for example looking at it as a boundary
regulation process so users figuring out
well what they want to share in to whom
based on the the social circumstances
and the challenge when you move online
is that it can be difficult to control
those boundaries because you have to a
priority set up those rules about well
who can see what and then the actual
interaction just occurs asynchronously
and can occur no after the fact and as
well it affects the temporal boundaries
I mean once you put something online it
can it stay there forever and be
difficult to actually remove so a
definition of framework I found very
useful when thinking about privacy and
social network sites is contextual
integrity this was proposed by Helen
nisam bomb as a way to explore and
explain some of the privacy problems
with a public surveillance so she was
interested in explaining why if there's
there's a camera video in you in a
public space and broadcasting that over
the Internet why even though you're in
public why people might still consider
that a privacy problem in a privacy
intrusion and a lot of the current
ethical or law frameworks did not really
explain why that would still be a
privacy issue if you're in public so
similar to a lot of the social
psychology definitions she posits that
information sharing is governed by the
social context and there are norms about
what is appropriate to share in that
context so she calls us norms of
appropriateness so for example it's
appropriate and even expected to share
your medical history with your doctor
but not appropriate to share your full
employment history probably with your
doctor but it would be appropriate to
share your full employment history with
a potential employer and not your
medical history so it's not so much that
one is more private than the other but
that there's different contexts in which
one is appropriate and one is not and
the other kind of norm is how that
information flows between parties so
that's norms of distribution so again it
would be appropriate and expected for I
know my doctor to share some of my
medical information with my insurer in
order to get paid but not with my
employer even though my employer may pay
for my insurance so privacy problems
then will occur when information that
might be appropriate in one
text is inappropriately shared in
another so again it's not about you know
there's no necessarily information
that's always public or always private
but it really depends on that context I
find this to be very appropriate to
describe some of the issues in social
networking because users are in a very
social context the challenge is that
online that what that context is the
cues for what is what context your inner
are different than they would be offline
and you a lot of those cues are about
well what kind of information flows are
on the site who can access the
information that I am posting or putting
up there and thus what is the context
that I am in and that can be very
difficult to explain so this framework
hasn't really driven my research but i
think it's we're not really trying to
validate this particular definition but
instead i think it's it's been useful to
help explain some of the results we've
gotten and to point out some of the the
knees which is to help make that context
what those information flows are much
more concrete and so people can be more
aware of them in order to improve what
their privacy behaviors should be okay
so now to start with the the studies and
the work that I've done so we started
off looking at general profiles on
social network sites and started looking
at Facebook as this was back in two
thousand seven it was um users were
sharing a lot of their real information
it was not very anonymous and they did
have very homogenous profiles with a lot
of information and extensive privacy
settings so that's why we chose them and
we found that um oh we did focused
interviews with a sets of users about
their sharing and their profile usage
and how they were how they were managing
their their that sharing in their
profile and we found that users were
considering they weren't just trying to
share everything with everyone they were
considering what's a post based on what
was safe and acceptable to share so
safety for most of our participants
meant not being able to be stalked or
located by a stranger what
meant that they took a lot more care
posting contact information than things
like interests and books and activities
that you know didn't matter to share
with strangers they couldn't find them
based on that and as far as what was
appropriate for a lot of these pieces of
profile information the purpose of that
information was not so much for their
good friends who already knew a lot
about that person but was really more
geared towards new acquaintances new
friends people they were meeting and so
what was appropriate was what they would
be willing to share with someone they
would recently met so in that case
birthdays and hometowns were quite
acceptable and were shared quite a lot
by our participants almost all
participants share their birthday in
hometown but interestingly things like
politics and religion were considered
more private by some and we're shared a
lot less than birthdays in hometown now
if you have a security perspective you
know birthdays on home town we consider
to be pretty sensitive for competitive
reasons so it's interesting again that
because of that social context users
don't see it that way in addition it was
easy to overlook the reach of your
information users generally started they
created their profile added a lot of
information upfront thought about the
broad audiences that might view it but
then as they went through their daily
interactions they interacted with a
fairly small group of often close
friends and so sometimes made decisions
based on sharing with those close
friends overlooking the fact that well
there's a lot more people that can view
that information this is my favorite
example um it was a participant who was
talking about how they weren't really
comfortable strangers during their
profile so they took care with what they
posted and yet this was one of the few
participants who actually posted quite
you know fairly publicly at the time it
wasn't completely public it was open to
the network so it was open to all of UNC
Charlotte this was a student um he had
his full phone number and an address and
so my student actually directly asked
him well why did you decide to share
that and he stated well it was because I
changed phone numbers and moved and I
wanted to communicate without my with my
friends but oh that actually probably
wasn't a good idea
really take that down and never thought
about having strangers having access to
it and actually after the study he did
set that as a friend's only a piece of
information so we named this phenomenon
and I'm sure others have named it
similarly that the shrinking perceived
audience so participants seemed to at
first think about the broad audiences as
they were creating their profiles and
adding information but as they went
through their daily interactions the
actual mental model of who they were
aiming for was their close friends and
they were overlooking the fact that oh
yeah strangers can view it so they were
consciously aware if you ask them can
stranger's view your profile yes but
when it came down to those regular you
know individual decisions that was
overlooked and this may have also been a
of something that contributed to that
Cliff Lampley lampe also did a study and
found that you know students in
particular weren't didn't think that
teachers and strangers would really be
looking at their profile why would they
want to so that may also be another
thing that's contributing to it even
though yeah strangers could but why
would they be viewing my information so
what they were posting and their their
privacy behaviors were more based on
this smaller audience participants also
spent very little time sort of updating
their settings and updating their
profile and really did that when
something prompted reflection and often
that was something creepy happening so a
stranger contacted them they were passed
on campus and someone said hi I saw you
on facebook someone started calling them
and that changed then that often
resulted in privacy settings being
changed or information being taken down
um interestingly um the study also
caused that reflection that wasn't a
goal but one of the I think one of the
nice things we did in this interview is
not only do we have people sit down in
front of their own profile we ask them
to view the profiles of other users so
we ask them to view profiles of two
others in the study and up to that we
controlled and to talk about their
impressions what we wanted to see was
what our impressions of people who have
different privacy settings so the one
we control it actually we had set a
number of privacy settings we wanted to
see what their reaction was um and in
our daily lives even if we're viewing
people we don't know very well we're
usually not behaving in an evil manner
where we're harmless even if we're
snooping on someone we don't consider
that to be either strange behavior um
whereas in this study we asked
participants to look at people for no
reason of their own with an interviewer
standing over their shoulder asking them
what they thought so they really felt
like this sort of stranger I I think so
they really called out people who had a
lot of information that maybe shouldn't
have been posted on their profile and
then reflected on their own behavior and
yeah strangers can view my profile maybe
I need to change my behavior and there
were several who changed their privacy
settings not just the the one from the
previous example who changed their
privacy settings and became more private
or took down information after our study
and that really wasn't our intention but
sort of an interesting aspect of how can
we how can we promote that those
occasional moments of reflection where
where people can redress their their
privacy behaviors so one of the
implications of that study was the
importance of having a more accurate
mental model of your audience in mind as
you are you know interacting on the
social network site so um this led us to
try and create a new interface for
modifying privacy settings another
result of that previous study was users
had a hard time modifying the privacy
settings of Facebook and sometimes they
were actually plain wrong they thought
they had done something and hadn't so we
also wanted to make something that was
more usable and to promote more frequent
modification of privacy settings so we
call this audience view um and it
basically presents your privacy settings
as the view of your information from the
various audiences so you see actually I
can show you a live demo here where to
go
not working there okay this is just a
Java prototype made to look like
Facebook it doesn't it doesn't actually
tie into facebook at all so it's pretty
basic you have the audience's along the
top so friends friends of friends and
this was the audiences at the time in
facebook and then you can have sub
categories like family your best friends
that that you define so then you can go
and you what view the the information
that these folks can see and just click
on the lock boxes to show and hide
information and you can set settings for
a whole set of your friends which will
propagate down and the yellow boxes say
that one of the subgroups is shared and
one of the subgroups is not shared so
that's the yellow sort of says there's a
difference in the sub categories so we
we thought this would give the there
so our goal was to try and provide a
more accurate and concrete mental model
of the information sharing that's
occurring and there's a lot more visual
feedback as to the the impact of a
privacy setting it's very obvious you
you you click the lock box the
information hides it Gray's out so it
conveys a pretty a much more accurate
mental model so then we compared this
with existing Facebook interface and
indeed users were able to modify their
settings faster and with greater
confidence than Facebook and all
everyone preferred it when we compared
it to Facebook and they didn't really
talk about usability or ease of how easy
it was but instead talked about the more
their confidence in the control they
felt so it seemed like that visual
feedback was really important to the
users and they really liked having that
additional what is the outcome of my
making that decision um I want to talk
about this since Rob's in the audience
we also then compared this with an
alternative interface which is Rob
readers expandable grids and if you're
not familiar with that interface it's a
grid visualization um in this case the
audience's the friends the networks were
across the top and on the other axis was
the sets of information and again in
this case we tied it to the sets of
information that were in facebook and we
you know compared the these two
interfaces we were actually surprised by
how few performance differences there
were users in both were pretty much
equally accurate and confident um took
about the same amount of time despite
how very different those representations
were but what did happen was users had a
very clear and different preference so
those that preferred audience view like
the visual feedback and and the more
contextual nature of the interface those
that preferred expandable grids liked
having an overview all in one place they
felt like it would help them not
overlook a particular setting so you
know audience view is you know encompass
as a number of pages and so there's some
limitations there it can only grow so
much before it gets cumbersome so we
think the implications of this are that
well users value and would probably
be benefited by both a contextual kind
of representation and a more compact
sort of see the forest kind of
representation and they may have
different preference preferences for
what they value it at different times so
how can we combine the two and perhaps
give them the best of both worlds we
haven't actually looked at how to
combine audience view and expandable
grids yet so maybe we'll do that but I
think even for other kinds of privacy
settings interfaces being able to both
have that visual feedback of the impact
of your setting and not have to visit
many many many pages in our to do so
would be valuable yes does this include
also the information about the wall pose
and controllable to walk bold all those
pictures or is it just about mom so it
did to some extent include things like
what the wall post although not
individual wall posts um it included the
whole wall um so I go back to the
screenshot here actually we see on the
screen shot in this case the wall is
hidden so we did not get to the point of
well any individual posts you make you
might want to set settings on I think
that's that's still very important and
and that may get cumbersome in this type
of interface because how you wouldn't
want to see a list of everything and you
probably want to make that decision
while you're posting and not in some
separate interface so another
disadvantage of this interface and and
also of expandable grids is that just
separate interface you're not
interacting with it while you are adding
your information while you're
interacting with people on the site it's
still a separate activity and so we're
very interested in how we pull more of
those decisions into the actual activity
on the site itself and we're working on
that but I think that's a very hard
problem for something like you know this
very calm potentially complex set of
privacy settings if you really did want
to go find Grange so
so next we looked at photo sharing on
social network sites and the particular
issue on social network sites with photo
sharing is that lots of people are
uploading photos potentially of you and
tagging those photos so that they are
now linking that photo with your profile
and now that photo is viewable on your
profile so your profile information is
no longer fully controlled necessarily
by you other people are making decisions
as to the content of your profile and so
we imagine that there were some issues
surrounding that and wanted to look at
that in more detail so again we started
with a formative study a set of focus
groups and we talked to participants
about photo sharing in general but very
quickly the issue of this very issue of
people uploading photos that I don't
like and being tagged in them and what
do I do about that and very quickly that
the notion of ownership came up and the
prevailing view was that those who took
the photo or or uploading the photo were
the owners and they should have the
right to do whatever they want with that
photo it's their photo so if they want
to upload it they should share it but
they have more of a social obligation to
respect the privacy and the wishes of
those in the photo so they would like
these this prevailing view would likely
reject any sort of privacy mechanisms or
everyone's a co-owner and has you equal
say in how this photo should be viewed
or shared or etc they really did feel
like the owners have more rights but yet
there's still somehow a social
obligation that they have towards the
people in the photo unlike general
profile privacy settings where people
were concerned about strangers and
stalkers they were most concerned with
people they already knew people in their
social circles so this was about
identity management more than anything
um so you know not surprisingly ah the
students didn't want their parents or
siblings to see the partying photos
people didn't necessarily you know
always want their work colleagues to see
some of the
more personal photos so is about you
know managing the reach of of that
individual photo the people who are
already in your social circles and there
was also also expressed almost a feeling
of helplessness everyone had some story
of some photo that they didn't want up
that someone had posted and really felt
like if you know if you're on facebook
even if you're not you're going to have
photos posted that you don't really
appreciate being online by someone else
and there's not a whole lot you can do
about it on tagging is does something at
least removes the photo from your
profile but everyone was very well aware
that was still out there probably other
people could find it you know it may not
be hard for for your family to find that
photo of you partying you if it's not on
your profile because it's on your best
friend's profile for example yeah it was
dad properly then at least you have some
control over the flow of information if
it's not tagged at all then well you
know all bad son yes and actually um
several participants expressed the
privacy benefits of tagging because at
least they knew there was a photo out
there they may not like it but at least
they were made aware that this photo
existed and was out there and if they
really didn't like it they could take
some action offline they had to you know
go and ask the owner to please take that
down or something but oftentimes that
didn't work because you know the owners
felt like they had a right to share it
and so sometimes depending on what the
photo was and the relationship you had
people didn't feel as much of an
obligation to actually take the photo
down or do what you wanted with it
Stewart there are a lot of a lot of
these questions where how how users will
respond will depend very heavily on the
language you use
and the language of tagging rent makes
it sound like well someone took a
picture and now they're tagging it those
are all things that belong to them
whereas if you were the question you
know if someone takes a photo and wants
to us publicly associate your account
with that photo I think you get a very
different response in a survey or in a
focus group if things are worded in that
way right and and we were aware of that
in that and we wonder if on different
sites this sort of prevailing view would
be different because Facebook implies
the way Facebook is set up the person
who uploads the photo has more
permissions right they they're the ones
who can choose album level permissions
they're the ones that can approve or
deny tags and so we're not sure if
partly this this view of owners having
more rights is because of the way sites
are currently set up and if sites were
made differently and had different
language if people would one disagree
with and not use it or n to have a
different view of well maybe we should
all be co-owners if you're posting this
picture I want equal rights to it but at
least at the moment on facebook users
didn't felt seemed to feel very
uncomfortable with the idea of
manipulating someone else's photo we had
actually as part of the focus group put
up a showed them an interface where
maybe you could blur out your your own
face did prompt discussion not really as
a potential solution but really to prom
discussion around we thought you know
they probably hadn't thought about a lot
of privacy mechanisms and they thought
well that's neat but I don't know that
I'd really use that because of that you
know someone else is an owner and I
would really feel uncomfortable except
in some extreme situations impacting
someone else's photo but again that may
partly be because of them nothing to do
with the photo in some sense right its
your right of privacy of your account
not associating with things you don't
want your account associated yeah and
this is this is a situation where you
actually you know if you think about
other contexts that would allow this
you would find them outrageous right
someone someone can associate email with
you even though you never sent it or
yeah if absolutely right I'm actually
surprised that this is not one of the
things that say I think is is is
focusing on in when they're going after
facebook because it's just so from an
architectural perspective so glaring
that what is normally a user's domain is
not their domain in this particular case
yeah and I think some of the users
perhaps they're pretty they're their
lack of concern over it is also because
it's a very convenient way to share
photos um and they that convenience
maybe outweighing how in other contexts
this would just seem like a very strange
mechanism that yeah this content can be
associated with your identity when you
didn't know what you didn't upload it
nothing think it came from sweat I
thought you could say your preferences
so that you had to approve any time your
tags eyes you know that's um I don't
think that's the case um you can set a
privacy preference to show all tagged
photos but they're all grouped as one
set of you know all photos you are
tagged in you can set the settings for
that but that's an all-or-nothing if you
only have one photo you don't like it
doesn't really help there so question
the back hello having formal circuit an
email with all the baking even knowing
about it looks to me like worse the
studies how to fight his ghost yes so
and they did Dayton and I've actually
anecdotally note a couple people who
joined facebook just so they could
monitor their photos even they knew pub
pictures were up there of them so at
least if they were on facebook they knew
it was there and they could at least
deal with it and other ways it was also
interesting people talked about changing
their physical behavior you know
avoiding the people who tended to take
the photos that ended up on facebook so
users were aware of this problem and but
there was just a lot of helplessness the
expressed and which was surprising
people really and yet there's not a big
for it so that's why I was surprised um
yeah I'll take a couple asked questions
other so speaking of exes in the middle
course I'm going to do this this option
three for the fourth or whatever that
means having to eat down power of ten
that's being used no I don't I don't
have any data and for all our
participants again these are photos
where they look bad I mean they weren't
the kind you would report they were you
know I woke up in the morning and my
hair was going crazy and my friends
thought that was funny or or I was
drinking and my coaches even though I'm
legal age my coaches I'm a sports team
my coaches don't want drinking photos of
me posted even though even if they're
very you know if there's nothing wrong
with them you know I'm just at a bar
holding a beer we're not supposed to do
that so it wasn't so much the that
seemed to be the concern of a lot of
users not the extreme case of a very
inappropriate photo that might get
reported hmm ask users about behavioral
changes in response to a feeling of
inability to control the release of this
kind of photos like don't go to the bar
and drink heavily before a game that
your coach doesn't way to be seen
drinking ash um they did comment on
avoiding people's cameras when they were
when they were doing things that they
didn't want to end up on facebook so
number of users commented on that but
not so much on the not doing the
behavior in the first place so much but
you know this is also of you know we
didn't have a large number of
participants either so so based on that
study we came up with a number of design
considerations if you were to try to
address some of these these privacy
issues with photo sharing first there
was still a huge social value to photo
sharing they were willing to put up with
all these problems because they wanted
to share their photos and a lot of the
issues were about identity management
user generally can identify specifically
who they don't want to see their photo
it's not so much about strangers in this
case usually the tools would need to
adhere to at least the the notions of
ownership that users have on that site
in order to manage the tensions that are
between these owners and tagged users
and help them negotiate that users
desire a way to take immediate action
and perhaps one way to manage this
tension is to bring that negotiation
into the privacy tools right now there's
really not a lot of negotiation I can
untag but even then people can retag and
a number of participants talked about
that happening at being a competitive
cycle of untagging andrey tagging and
otherwise that negotiation has to move
completely out of the tool and offline
if you really want a photo taken down so
how about bringing that negotiation in
so with these considerations in mind we
designed an additional mechanism we
think it's an additional tool in the
toolbox we called restrict others and we
wanted this to to be a more
collaborative negotiation between the
owner and tagged users in order to
hopefully change or at least reduce this
tension so we really wanted to put a
little more tension on the owner to
fulfill that moral obligation as our
participants referred to it as so what
this interface does and this is just an
interface prototype it would allow a
tagged user to specify who they would
want this photo restricted from and so
individuals or groups of people that
they wanted it restricted from so that
fits with you know there's usually a set
and often it was a small set of people
they didn't want to see that photo
exactly or your mom and dad or a small
family group or work colleagues or
church colleagues that was the common
ones stated and you can state an
optional reason and this would then send
a message to the owner and it would say
you in this case Heather wants to hide
this photo from six users it would not
actually list out the those names
because that would be actually providing
an additional information that was not
they could be used for blackmail or
other purposes so that's that's almost
too revealing it's putting the tension
back on the tag user and so you know
again you notice this this can take you
know very quick action and it tries to
bring that negotiation into the
interface yeah who cannot see it
is backwards blacklist usually don't
work and it shouldn't stand or mind
sending it more effective if you say who
can stream and maybe tools that would
explicitly take some people off of the
safe list but I'm concerned about you
leave somebody off the blacklist yeah
and and I mean the reason we went with
the blacklist was again because most of
our participants could name that list of
you know I don't want you know mom dad
brother sister to see this and it was
usually actually fairly small it wasn't
a huge group um there were probably some
of those photos again which they didn't
want anyone to see because you know they
woke up it examples use multiple times
you know I just woke up and I looked her
terrible or whatever my hair was looking
awful so it wasn't just about the
drinking this wouldn't necessarily be
good for those but for some of those
others where it's it's that you know the
smaller social circles that they really
don't want to see perhaps this would
address those concerns so yeah I agree
um you know this is a blacklist method
but it did seem to match some of the the
ways people were thinking about you know
I don't mind a lot of people seeing it
but you know not mom and dad not Church
not whatever it was and so we did
evaluate but this was a lab study we
implemented that interface prototype as
a facebook application so um it could
access users actual photos so we asked
them to choose one of their photos and
play the role of you know restricting
others they knew it wasn't going to
actually work so this this was a role
playing even though it was they were
operating on their own photos they seem
to understand the interface we didn't
give them any training and felt like it
was lightweight and would be fairly easy
to use takes a little more time than
untagging so they reportable that would
take a little more effort well that's
untagging his one button this you
actually have to list out the users but
they did appreciate the fact that it was
more collaborative you know couldn't be
undone you know someone couldn't retag
me again and then we asked them to play
the role of an owner and sent them a
request as though
it had been sent to them and would you
allow this person to deny this from I
can't remember how many users we said
six eight something like that and many
said you know would I don't see why I
wouldn't in that case seems silly so it
did they did seem to feel like in many
cases that that was a reasonable request
and that they would want to satisfy that
but there were still a few participants
who did not who said no deny and their
reasons we're interesting a couple of
them said well this doesn't seem like a
very dangerous photo there's nothing
going on here why would someone want to
hide that photo from anyone um and
others so I don't really know these
people in the photo so why would I care
so there does seem to be this is relying
on having social consequences and so if
you don't know the person you don't care
about what they think you're not likely
to feel like you have any sort of social
obligation to protecting their privacy
but perhaps if you do um and it seems
like a reasonable request you would be
likely to to grant that study where they
were working on so when they requested
when they did the restricting themselves
it was on their real photos we had
intended that a message would get sense
about their real photo but the API
changed like a couple days before the
study and we didn't realize it and we
had default in there if it couldn't find
one of their photos it would choose one
of ours they all got sent one of our
photos um that had me and the my student
in it and so that's where I think those
who said it would be reasonable we're
playing that role they were thinking of
themselves in that role those who said
it wasn't we're looking at this photo
going what's wrong with this photo I
don't know these people um I don't care
so in the end I actually think it was
kind of good because we saw you know if
you don't have that social consequence
this mechanism isn't going to
necessarily work either but if you do
and many users thought well in a real
situation I might again it's a lab study
I would really like to deploy this
because as I've talked about it there's
a lot of subtleties that that people
have brought up so for example well if
I'm the owner I might want to know I
mean I actually don't care
so much if my friend hides it from all
the people who aren't in my social
circle I don't care you know I'm not
really trying to share it with them
anyway so who cares that they want to
hide it from people who I don't know but
if I if they're trying to hide it from
my best friend I might want to know that
and so I think there's some interesting
places where this may need to be I don't
know I think we would need a deployment
study in order to to be able to tell how
much in practice users would really
employ that and what some of these
subtleties might be when they start to
look at six users well who are those
people would they really accept that or
where they start to ask questions or not
yes Stuart because in order to protect
personal information they have to list
Morgan personal information that is I
have to tell you who it is that I'm
sensitive about and where there may be
potential tension or so I have to give
up what I'm giving up maybe worse than
then what I'm trying to protect in the
first place and that now I have to say
yeah there is some tension between me
and this person or this is the person I
really don't want the sketchy photos to
go to so if there's not a great
relationship of trust there I might be
doing more damage to myself by using
this interface because now you know
exactly where to hit me yeah I agree I
agree um I absolutely agree i think this
is potentially one additional tool but
it clearly doesn't work for all
situations where you don't have a social
relationship where the person you're
trying to hide it from there's some
tension going on there I agree so I
think there's room for other mechanisms
this is what we came up with when we
really sort of tried to go through those
considerations but then that presents
itself with its own list of potential
issues so the participants all seem to
like the idea of it and cook and and
came up with when being interviewed yeah
I could see there there being a few
photos where I might actually want to
use that but it's not going to cover
everything so I think that's one of the
challenges here is that because of these
social relationships and and how this
all interplays with your identity
management and and you know people
having this different ownership tension
going on one solution isn't going to fix
all of them unless you went to this very
kind i think complex model of you know
co access control but then I don't think
users would use that because it's too
complicated and and and again they might
rebel against well I don't it's their
photo I don't really want to be setting
my settings for that so I don't know
what the solution is to cover everything
I think we need more investigation here
that you know the reason the comfortable
with this is because they seem to
exhibit a great job trust in the
provider right so they said i will now
face book a serious pointing out of
house for their weaknesses are in some
sense and then facebook decided to well
you know someday you get an email from
facebook at sells well if they you put a
thousand dollars in the ecology or you
know will reveal disorder to this you
know you your worst enemy right if that
peroxidation that while they would be
very much uncomfortable with doing it
this way and the other thing that comes
out of this is that you're proposing key
mechanism that does blacklisting
whitelisting I wonder if even possible
um yeah I mean again the blacklisting
seem to go along with how users were
talking about who you know they wanted
to hide it from a few people they
weren't really thinking it you know is
again it's not all every photo that
they're talking about it was there's
always a few of those photos you don't
want up there and they really seem to
think why I'd rather hide it that was
their conception now again that could be
impacted by how the current sites work
but we were trying to at least see if we
could reflect that and what what
participants would think about that I
agree with you in in the trust of the
site we we were looking at for these
both of these sets of the general
profile and the photos we weren't
looking at trust and privacy with
respect to more the data privacy the
fact that you know facebook has access
to this and what do I want facebook to
have access to people do seem to trust
the site for good or bad and so we
weren't can we were not looking at that
issue in this these particular sets of
studies even looking beyond that issue
there still issues of privacy with just
how other users can can access my stuff
so we were more interested in that
hmm about the sum one of them is did any
users that you talked to ever think
about any legal mechanisms that might be
put into place to help them manage
privacy and punish people who violate
their wishes and that would get up the
Facebook thing as well and then the
other thing is if you imagine that
there's pretty much no way you can
possibly control every leak of
information about to unless you have no
friends and you live in the desert by
yourself wait molar electronic
communication and satellites then could
you think about what would you think
about a system that helps people manage
the spin of a leak rather than managing
whether or not there's a week at all um
so dealing with your first question um
we didn't ask really people about law
and legal and policy questions so and
they didn't really volunteer any so but
i think that was also we weren't really
asking them about that the second
question I think that's a great idea um
and we have in my group talked about
more general mechanisms you know not
just you know we were focused again on
there's this very small piece of you
know photo sharing their personal
information all over the place on a
variety of sites how would you manage
all of that have an overview but we
haven't yet come up with we haven't done
a lot of work in that so I I think
that's a great idea and something that
would be very interesting to investigate
okay so the last domain on social
network sites that we looked at with
social applications this is the
application platform that many of you
are probably familiar with you download
a third-party application I it plays a
game or does a survey or it offers some
service to you and the interesting thing
with applications is I think this is a
place where users consider themselves to
be in the social context still of the
rest of the social network site they're
sharing with their friends and yet
there's some additional privacy
implications having to do with the fact
that these third-party developers are
getting access to this and now this
personal information is flowing off of
facebook to other places so we wanted to
to look at this particular problem so
just in case you're not very familiar
with how the application platforms work
Google's OpenSocial operates very
similarly
and there's some some differences
depending on how the site implements it
but in general you know an application
that you authorize can pull a lot of
your profile data in order to do some
service so perhaps this one it would
give you back a movie recommendation in
addition it can pull the information
from your friends depending on their
their settings so it could pull profile
information from say Bob and Charlie and
they have not authorized this
application and are not aware
necessarily that you are even using it
and this might be useful for example it
could generate a movie recommendation
that the three of you could wash
together but the problem with this is
that when you authorize an application
this is just one list I have the same
and complete it changes also all the
time of all of the stuff you are giving
that application whether potentially
giving that application whether it needs
it or not and there are some back-end
mechanisms but in general I don't think
they're particularly strong and you
could make a good case for a lot of
pieces of data why you might need it and
so we suspected most users had no idea
that this was going on so we wanted to
look at this a little more
quantitatively and again anecdotally I
was asked a lot about this when people
heard I was dealing with Facebook
privacy and they really judged based on
this little statement here it's pulling
your profile information that it
requires to work um not anything that it
wants to so that's pretty ambiguous but
they were really taking that to mean
well if it's not really going if it
doesn't make sense to use you know my
birthday why would it pull my birthday
it shouldn't be able to do that so that
seemed to be how people were forming
their mental models you know they could
also read blurbs you on the privacies
policy and and and on the this is a
screenshot from a few months ago I think
it's probably changed by now um you know
and just what applications do and how
the platform works but that didn't seem
to be getting into people's
understanding so we gave a survey and to
really find out what they thought was
being shared and so we asked them both
about applique
they had installed in applications their
friends had installed and this is
applications or friends they had
installed or they had authorized and
they correct answer is yes they have
access to all of this and as you can see
um you know they were pretty high on
thinking oh yeah my name and picture was
able to be accessed but when it came to
other things like you know marketplace
listings you know significant other a
lot of you moved to a lot of the know
and don't know so they really didn't
understand they were potentially giving
all this information and then we asked
about friends applications their friends
had installed for the top three that
that's yes that information is public
you can't really prevent other
applications from accessing it the rest
do depend on your privacy settings we
did look at a number of her participants
we're also doing an interview we did
look at our participants settings and
most of them had the default open
settings so this these should have been
very high so actually isn't always yes
it depends on your settings but most of
them allowed it so okay so they don't
know no they did not and we asked a few
we asked a few things that Facebook
didn't have on its site so we and these
weren't in this order we ordered them
based on the based on the nose but they
were they were in yes right yeah no no
one did that no one said yes your social
security number was was shared and we
had a few others on there that were not
shared because we didn't want to ensure
that that that happened and I don't
remember we did look at were there
people you know was it that a couple
people got it all right and then other
people were very wrong and it really did
seem I don't remember if even one person
got it all right so I think there was
just general confusion um-hmm um
twenty-something 20-something no more
than that no 20 25
24 then maybe I'm sorry I'm not
remembering so he also asked okay well
who do you think you're sharing with not
surprisingly many thought it was mostly
they're friends again that social
context they seem to be judging based on
their interaction with applications you
know they've seen applications okay they
seem to have my name my photo they seem
to have my friends photos a lot of the
ones I use but probably I don't know if
anyone had ever used an application that
accesses your marketplace or your
significant other and then we asked what
would you be willing to share so despite
the confusion and really thinking they
were mostly just sharing with their
friends they this seemed to be not so
sure they still most reported they
didn't really want to share everything
um so you know name and picture seemed
okay but as we got down just and we had
the whole long list but this is just a
subset of them um you know some of the
ones like political views and work
history no no no reason to share them
and so you know this is not reflecting
their behavior and what's actually
happening happening on the platform at
all to hypothesize about what could what
scenario could you come up with why you
would want to share this piece of the
ADA with advertisers no we didn't ask
that we did ask in general what your
concerns were with application usage and
sharing information with applications um
and most people again reported the
identity management stuff you know
sharing you know results of surveys with
people who you know about you know what
don't know what dawood animal I'm like I
don't want everyone on my social
networks seeing that that's where more
of their concerns a few people came up
with more advertising III work i don't
want businesses to get my data for
advertising and only one person really
came up with the new people being able
to do more malicious things like
identity theft and even that wasn't
because developers already had access to
it it was he came up with a scenario of
you know some would make an application
where they could pose as a woman and
then get all this information out of me
so not a single participant you know had
had even sort of a rudimentary
understanding of that all this
information
is flowing off of facebook potentially
to other developers um we did have pry
the majority were college aged but then
we we did have I think not remembering
very much now um we did have a number of
users in late 20s early 30s and early
40s so we tried to get away from the
University for for some of that so they
weren't all students and even so the
students were older but they were not
the full they were there were not a full
representative sample of Facebook's
population conversation just Facebook
itself don't forget focus on the binder
you know so tremendous amount about
these applications some of them are
shady you know my antenna situation here
but like well myspace once an escape you
look cost and add on myspace if you use
myspace is yet then we can do things
like target I didn't of expecting
mothers that you know products hoping
for that carry with myself same with
Facebook right so I mean did you ask
them to see if the quality increased
quality and there are lots of ads that
they care because of Facebook dying so
much about them do they see that as you
know Boone's of some sort or do you see
this magnitude we didn't ask that
question and we none of our questions
really came close to addressing that
particular aspect so I think that be an
interesting question again there seems
to be this implicit trust of facebook
although we again we didn't dig into
that and I think that would be very
interesting
to look at more can you talk about how
you might assess the strength of
conviction that the people that they
study participants have about their
feelings for privacy like if you try to
convince them that it was a good idea to
give out your political views to
software developers and how hard would
you have to try to get them to go ahead
and do it like money well that'd be
interesting um yeah that would actually
be quite interesting wait I mean all
we've done is is just for we always use
the west and survey just to kind of make
sure we and and we had the traditional
breakdowns of pragmatism analyst but we
never really tried to push in people's
what they'd be willing to give away for
privacy I think that would be an
interesting study to look at and see if
that correlates to their behaviors on
facebook I think I'd be interesting so
I'm not really answering your question
but I'd like to move on before before we
so I can get to the last the last
solution here so our first solution was
well you know they're out there giving
away everything well let's at least
provide some more fine-grain access
control and can we do that in a way at
the the sort of the authorization stage
where people would find this lightweight
and would actually interact with it and
then would help them build a mental
model of what's being accessed or not so
in this interface you know what pulls
your concrete information is not just
saying well it's your know it's your
friends it's actually pulling the
information so you can see what's being
shared it's also picking a random friend
to give you the awareness that you're
also sharing potential your friends
information and it's filling that that
in I'm and then you can check and
uncheck the boxes to share information
so fairly straightforward sort of access
control but if this would work if users
would be willing to actually check and
uncheck those boxes and modify their
their policies otherwise they're just
going to accept whatever the application
asks for and we want to look at what
strategies might they use and would they
actually go about protecting themselves
what didn't you increase their awareness
of everything so we tested this by
simulating the installation experience
so again we built that as a facebook
application so it could pull people's
real information to populate the
interface we told them they were testing
an application container that had
additional capabilities
we wanted them to install or authorize
11 random applications and then we
varied the scenarios from being you know
having short policies long policies
being very sort of appropriate to the
context of the application and things
that just looked very inappropriate and
wanted to see what people would do so we
found there were really two sets of
users and we weren't trying to
categorize perfectly but really more
qualitatively describe what was going on
there was about half our users modified
some of their policies they uncheck
boxes in this case we went with a
default to share i'm so yun check boxes
and the other half went through all 11
and just hit except except except except
for the most part um so they weren't
really motivated to to interact with the
interface um and the on the left this is
a where what we asked for was fairly
appropriate it was still sensitive
information was appropriate for the for
the application so a horoscope would ask
for your birthday and even the people
who were modifying their policies still
shared things that were appropriate we
actually thought hometown was
appropriate because it would what stars
you were born under or whatever turned
out it wasn't so much those who were
more motivated chose not to to add that
and I think the person here in the in
the unmotivated group actually had a
horoscope application already so they
chose not to add it because they already
had one not so much because of a privacy
decision this was one that was we asked
a very inappropriate data that it made
no sense for what the application did
and as you can see a lot of the the
motivated users actually did not share
some of this this information that did
not make sense well even though they
still added the application a number of
them out of the application but just
restricted that sharing so it seems like
well just having this access control
type of interface some users will use it
and they will protect themselves more
and actually as a response potentially
protect their friends based on how we
propose this mechanism of work um but
they also seem to not pay too much
attention if they didn't have the the
piece of data filled in on their profile
that could be a problem if later they
went back and added that information the
profile they might forget that they were
already sharing it and the biggest
problem was still that oh this
authorization seems to occur
before they ever get to the application
so they're making decision based on the
name almost no one went and looked at
the application information they didn't
read the explanations for what why they
wanted that data they made very fast
decisions and they judged based on the
name and they wanted to get to the
application through the process so we
think that's fairly realistic even
though this was a lab study and so we're
we're now thinking about well how can we
move this decision pass authorization
point and let users express these
privacy settings as they're interacting
with the application so that's something
we're currently working on so that's one
of my next steps and I'll try and
summarize here real quickly another is
we're also trying to look at some more
general mechanisms not just not for
specific types of social network site
policies that might help users make
privacy decisions and this is work
that's going to be presented next week
at the symposium on usable privacy and
security we were looking at this should
look familiar it's the application
access control but what we put on that
we just thought would be interesting is
this bar but we didn't test it in our
last study so this study was all based
around well would users with this bar
change users decision would they take
that into account and making their
decision as to whether to share
information or not so and this is called
social navigation as an example of
social navigation using other users
behavior to help inform your own so we
set up a study around just that a
controlled experiments use Mechanical
Turk to get a good number of users and
found that um just this bar didn't have
any impact that we could find based on
our sample but it did have somewhat of
an impact if you made it much stronger
the queue much stronger by painting this
red line across the whole of the whole
data field to show that you were sharing
something that the majority people
weren't and that did have an impact but
still not a large impact there was
probably a twenty percent less sharing
of those data items and users didn't
really report that they that they paid a
lot of attention to it it was sort of
middle of the road they notice
it but didn't think it was really
impacting their decisions much so it
seems to have a modest impact and it
might be useful it's a very simple
mechanism but it needs to be really
strong and some of the things I'm
interested in now are will you know was
it the actual social mechanism or is it
just there's a red bar there and and if
you manipulate what that red bar means
how much does that impact their decision
so that's sort of our next step there's
is looking at these kinds of cues that
might help people make decisions okay so
in conclusion I think you know all my
work has really you've been about you
know yes users are sharing a lot but
they still have privacy issues they
still have privacy concerns and needs
and I think we can do a lot with
creating additional more usable
interfaces you'll create that that
better awareness of their context so
even if they're not manipulating privacy
settings perhaps they're choosing what
to post with a more awareness of where
it's going so they will have fewer
privacy intrusions and we're continuing
to look at how to how to provide more
general guidance to users and making
privacy policy decisions and so to pull
those decisions closer to their regular
interactions and activities on a site
instead of still as separate you know
policies and interfaces so I'm at an
hour I will you want to thank all my
students whose work I'm really
representing here and all my
collaborators and I will take some
additional questions suppose we could
miraculously come up with a ninja thing
where everyone completely understands
what is exposed and room and you know
and is very happy with it's very
intuitive isn't a very good argument
saying that this is absolutely the last
images that Facebook is going to use the
conclusion is not unintentional the
ambiguity is therefore reason because
they were very powerful incentive for
you to be confused about exactly what
you've exposed and they will always bias
it toward your exposing your also be
surprised if you expose
rather than less when you finally figure
it out they just change everything I
mean it isn't that the fundamental
problem here I think there is a
fundamental problem there yes because
the sites who are building their
businesses off of our personal
information have motivation to get us a
share as much of it as possible so I
agree with you and I don't actually
expect necessarily facebook to implement
many of these however it's also up to
the consumer to choose which sites they
use they have choice um yes there are
network effects and and all of that but
I don't think Facebook you know it is
here to stay necessarily for the long
haul we've seen already users are very
fickle and will jump so you I do think
if privacy can become more of a
commodity to users there will be more
incentive so I think of an interesting
fundamental issue is how do we help
users to value and understand that so
that it does become over commodity they
do demand it and then they go to those
places where they have you no more
usable interfaces better sites you know
if you can show that there's an
interface that is much more intuitive
and the people respond to much better
than what does or at least it
demonstrates the gap between what what's
available and what you know what they're
using which would put a selfie
yeah so I think there's potential
there's also potential with policy you
know policy being stronger and more
influential insights at least having to
show they're doing a little more than
they're doing your but again I think
it's going to fall back on the consumer
um which you know we've all shown
there's issues of privacy people are
willing to give away their information
to get useful stuff in return so I don't
have a necessarily solution yet but and
I don't want to pick just on facebook
it's been a very easy platform to study
because of the application platform
that's why we've used it so much we're
trying to get away from facebook and and
we are looking at other sites and also
looking at mobile on the mobile platform
you know there's a lot of the same
application oriented issues going on
there um but yeah i agree with you into
the policy this one time two times
they're picking a random guys computer
and say pretend XYZ company has sued us
and you're doing a pre-trial discovery
have you thought of similar red team
attacks laxity like safety is classic
The Dukes are up so Devon because um I
think that would be interesting I think
that tends to work when you have an
authority who can do those attacks so if
you are within an organization they can
do those attacks and there are a number
a lot of different kinds of security
issues you know fishing there's been a
lot of proposed solutions to do that I
haven't looked at that it'd be
interesting to see how much users
respond in this case to you I could see
them responding positively if it's their
social network site usage thats related
to the company but if it's their
personal say facebook profile page would
they appreciate some organization trying
to teach them about what they should and
should not here is already inside the
menu lighters yeah
but a might cause that's that same kind
of reflection that our first study did
as well so so indelible folks remember
computer science so the first question
how do you thought of assessing there's
the financial of course that people put
on their privacy you can set up so what
makes us here's what I'm imagining it's
not vacation right so there's
application that's as well so mean
you're under privacy and every time I go
and update one of those knobs it gives
me you know why of dollars and then we
never find out much i'm going to pay to
review more more about myself yeah so
there have been some studies of that and
there's a whole group of people in
behavioral economics who study things
like that so the one that's coming to
mind that's been most recently with an
HDI was group it at CMU looked at well
if you had a you may be familiar with it
on Serge Edelman says thank you sir yeah
it looked at you know if you had hmm no
no actually it was where they looked at
would people buy items from a site based
on if the privacy ratings and so how yes
so how so how much would they be willing
to pay based on the privacy rating and
so there are people doing that those
kinds of experiments and again I think
they're very interesting to look at
commoditizing and really look the
economics around around privacy yeah
that does has been something I've done
yet
x yes so just that so following the dis
vendee you can you can easily imagine
putting together a team that will go
into your site and discover a
vulnerability or but can you put
together a team that can go into a site
discover what social value you're
getting or from share the same as in the
case of photos as you mentioned you a
month that are going up there we can all
find three that are disastrous but there
may be three billion that are actually I
so so I guess that's the desperate I we
focus too much on the easily discovered
problems who's out there measuring the
benefits from sharing of social capital
yeah one and that's one of the
interesting is about privacy is it it is
it is related to sharing i mean the four
especially a lot of these sites the two
are in some ways one in the same i'm
sharing and I'm not sharing with you and
I'm sharing with you and that is that is
a definition of privacy so I've been a
lot of our studies we've asked about
sharing not so much about privacy to try
not to get them to think to securely and
say things that might you know oh yeah I
should be a private person so I should
say that but I think it's hard to get at
both of those things at once still
because um there's a lot of issues going
on around the around the same thing and
different informations different and
different sites are different so yeah i
agree with you we've also talked about
and we haven't we never haven't
implemented this yet but and there are
aggregators that will go through and
sort of give you a view of all the stuff
that's accessible on you okay well what
if you could do that well what would you
want to do with that information then
what what's the next step after that you
know do you want all of this stuff out
there how would you go and now hide it
and set your settings and all from one
place so you can think of your you know
whole online persona and identity as
instead of this site in this site in
this site in this site and I think
that's something that I would suspect
we'll see more and more of as more and
more people join more and more sites
there's this we're just all very
separated some of that's good but it's
hard getting harder harder to manage all
these different pieces of content on the
different sites Rob really do a couple
of the other questions one thing I
really wonder about it is I think all of
us as privacy researchers then no
privacy place really really important
right but to an average user is it
something is it really attribute they
would use to jump sites is it that
important to them today mostly concerned
with all the other attributes of social
network like how easy it is to share
photos and how many of those brands are
on it all that stuff we're just private
income right yeah the list of all the
attributes people usage I don't know I
mean it's interesting and following the
progression of Facebook and some some
regards a lot of people who yeah we're
first study was three years ago they've
talked about Facebook MySpace we asked
them if they had other sites and they
said they like Facebook because it felt
more private and closed and and they
were more willing to be themselves now
those are the earlier adopters um I
think social network effects have taken
over and now everyone's on facebook at
least in the u.s. it's that's very
prevalent um and I've also seen just the
past few months again this is anecdotal
I haven't studied this but a lot more
people being more upset at Facebook and
privacy I mean more uncomfortable with
what Facebook's doing even though really
their privacy settings they've gone a
little more public but you can still be
that pretty much the same word several
years ago the settings are not any more
complicated than they were last year
even though suddenly now Facebook's
having changed them to respond to all
this media criticism
so I think it's going to come and go but
I think users if there was a site that
offered them everything else but was
more private I suspect they'd switch
that will not happen exactly so it is
one of many factors and and how to judge
what those factors are I mean you've
also that that group out of she was a 10
and why you are MIT who is making that
the distributed social network site
they've gotten a lot of press and
support again because it you're in
control of your information I think if
there were alternatives then we'll see
but I don't have a quantitative answer
to that but i think i'd be interesting
to study so i do think it is an aspect
that people will consider
yeah Facebook need not be terribly
motivated to you know sort of help with
this necessarily are they throwing on it
um but other people can create apps for
facebook they might help right so what's
the current state about us or the pool
of applications for facebook they also
that tell you who's been looking your
profile are you so the challenge of at
the applications is they have access to
your profile but they don't really they
can't affect your privacy settings um
right really good make you aware right
make it they could give you a report of
if another user looked at your
application they couldn't give you a
report of another you looked at your
baby could they do kind of like like I'm
thinking you know I started virus
children it run through my whole
computer is this no beer clean right you
could react that could run through and
safe and there was one well there was
one recently yeah I think sister was the
student I haven't done a scan I haven't
seen very many I have seen one that
would go in oh this was a few months ago
it would go in and check again because
it was an application had access it
would check what had access to and and
so it would prompt you to modify your
settings and then I saw people passing
that around through the newssheet but
that's the only one I've seen so I think
it's one it's still difficult you know
the app may be able to access profile
information but still can't read
everything all the internals of facebook
so I don't think there's been too much
of that and I also think more of us need
to try and be creative and think about
how to spread that awareness more so i
think there's both thank you very much